lorsque l'on saute aux critiques on
oublie aussi de regarder les choses qui
fonctionnent la chose que nous avons en
martinique première comme dans les
autres stations d'ailleurs n'ont plus
qu'un martinique première c'est d'être
un digital extrêmement puissant et
efficace le meilleur du réseau d'être
une radio mais aussi une télévision
c'est une force considérable qu aucun de
nos concurrents
non il faut en prendre conscience et
pour faire travailler ses trois médias
de façon logique de façon réfléchie en
identifiant les angles de traitement les
choix de projets comme on décide de
couvrir on réussir vraiment à montrer à
nos internautes auditeurs et
téléspectateurs que nous sommes un média
fort le média historique qu'ils ont
toujours connu donc pour moi c'est très
important et la première chance je l'aï
dit tout à l'heure ce n'est pas quelque
chose que j'ai nourri depuis que tout le
monde en parle dans l'ensemble du réseau
première la première j'en sais quelque
chose de fondamental on ne fait rien
seul un navire en service sans son
équipage et sans son capitaine
c'est une épave et c'est ce que l'on
doit comprendre alors ça lui semble delà
du déménagement
on va faire ce déménagement étape par
étape avec le personnel mais aussi je
l'espère vivement avec des martiniquais
parce que ils nous connaissent ils
connaissent clairière ils ont été
habitués à venir ici il ya des habitudes
qui ont été prises c'est un patrimoine
mais ce patrimoine il existe ne va pas
disparaître il va simplement être
transporté sur un autre site au coeur de
fort-de-france au coeur de la cité
martiniquaise aucun de la société
martiniquaise et moi ce que je nourris
envie d'organiser ce déménagement avec
la population avec des opérations tout
dépendra du dédommagement de la date du
déménagement effectif mais pour prendre
pas imaginer déménagement avec un enfer
d'organiser un déboulé un délai voilà ça
peut être ça aussi c'est à tomber
du carnaval ou à noël mais je suis pas
différent ce déménagement par étapes
avec les personnels mais aussi avec le
public qui nous fait confiance depuis
des années